bullying ideas YouTube intro hello and  welcome to the folding ideas YouTube  channel here you're going to find three  main kinds of content first are the  full-length episodes these range between  15 and 30 minutes long and consist of an  in-depth contextual analysis of a  specific subject be it a movie or a  television show or a social movement  second are the minisodes these tend to  be 2 to 5 minutes long and cover things  like jargon questions for viewers and  follow-ups to previous episodes third  are highlights from live streams which  they're highlights from from the live  streams so that's where you can expect  to find here on the channel I am most  active on twitter you can follow me  there at foldable human I also have an  ask fm page and we're technically on  Facebook you know what you're supposed  to say when you go out of these is like  like share subscribe like share  subscribe like share subscribe light  light light light share subscribe like  like share subscribe like